I'm back o
[Music]
Won Exxon
Dr. Fujishiro, etc.
Who
realized Inoue Calm down This is a dream
What are you mumbling?  I don't know why
it's milk,
why don't you? I can't drink the house that is the color of the god of death, what you say.
It's natural that I'm proud of my back
.
Uransatsu is a witch and ban And
Inoue is
a ghost of a pumpkin pumpkin
Ah Kurosaki-kun The strange thing about patchwork
is you.
What kind of monster is your sister or you
looking like? I'm the first bus I
'll explain what it's like if you open it.
Appearing in the form of a beautiful woman with wings on her back,
she attacks the man in 3 and
seduces her to suck up her life energy.
And so on